i mean i've as you might know spent a
lot of my adult life working with the
police um and
uh for me and for them it's it's a
dreadful blow and that's over and above
the the total devastation for sarah
everard's parents um that they must be
feeling it's unimaginable
but the fact that this man was a serving
police officer when he committed the
crime is
just horrifying really um and has made
all of us think hard about
hey how we how it happened in the first
place and be how we can prevent it in
the future
how damaged are the police as a result
of what happened
well i i think as you heard yesterday uh
from senior police officers uh they
recognized that this has
struck a a devastating blow to the
confidence that people have in in police
officers out in the public realm um but
also in in the met police in particular
um the circumstances that were revealed
yesterday around the the way this awful
monster perpetrated his crime using the
cover of being a police officer
raises a question mark in everybody's
minds and
you know from my point of view for that
well it's
obviously a terrible terrible
catastrophe for sarah everard and her
family for those thousands and thousands
of police officers out there who will
have to work harder um much harder uh to
win the public trust in in the realm and
particularly those of individuals it is
a very very difficult time
um the labour mp um harriet harman
believes that cressida dick um the head
of the met should stand down why do you
think she should keep her job
okay the the being the met commissioner
is i think one of the
possibly top three most difficult jobs
in the in the country uh you handle
enormous risk you're dealing with an
organization which is capable of amazing
things but at the same time uh things
can go badly wrong as they have done in
this
circumstance and what i want in a in a
pleasing leader is when awful calamities
like this happen and i think as
christopher said yesterday this is
you know probably the worst moment in
the 192 year history of the metropolitan
police um that when these awful things
happen i want a police leader who's
transparent willing to learn willing to
change and is has a conviction a
commitment
not to be defensive about the failings
of the organization and i think that's
what we're seeing in christopher dick
when there are failings of an
organisation it's the chief executive's
responsibility to take responsibility um
it's she is to all intents and purposes
the chief executive it's not the first
time on her watch that there have been
significant failings why should she keep
her job
well as i said okay it is the most
difficult job and in my experience
having worked with wester over many
years in a number of positions she is a
dedicated and talented and committed uh
police officer who is driving the
metropolitan police to ever greater
standards
of care and improvement and fighting
crime and she is committed to whatever
changes come out of the lessons learned
of this horrible episode um and that's
what i wanted a police leader someone
who's willing to to change frankly not
just in the metropolitan police but
across the whole of uh uk policing and
we are going through a period
of change in policing the fact that
we're recruiting all these extra police
officers and don't forget to get to our
20 000 extra we've got to recruit
a gross recruitment of about 45 000
officers altogether is a shot of of
youth and energy and different thinking
into british policing which i hope will
start to to change the culture for the
better
yeah okay so a serving police officer
arrests somebody
allegedly
puts their hands behind their back in
handcuffs puts them in a vehicle drives
them for two hours
rapes them on the back of the seat takes
them out of the vehicle
puts them in a fridge
burns them hides their phone and then
goes about their normal business
exchanges text messages with 15 other
metropolitan police officers who are now
also all under investigation
on her watch
yeah look the the the incident itself is
as you laid out case is just devastating
i mean i i can't get away from that and
i know that that all this all the
metropolitan police officers that i know
will be similarly ashamed and devastated
by it
uh the question in in our mind is is
what went wrong right my job is
effectively to to help the home
secretary to hold the police to account
about what went wrong how this monster
slipped through the net to become a
police officer um how we can make sure
it doesn't happen again and what we need
to learn i mean though as you said there
are a number of investigations and
inquiries taking place around this case
which i can't comment on but as those
conclude what we learn about how we can
make sure the police is a a better
organization um and has the trust
unquestioning trust of the british
people and i don't think there's any
question that that's been shaken by
these events
more than 750 metropolitan police
employees have faced sexual misconduct
allegations since 2010.
only 83 of those 750 have been sacked
750 metropolitan police employees faced
sexual misconduct allegations since 2010
many of them on her watch
look kay obviously it's important that
we have a very very robust uh
investigate internal investigation
function and one that is independent
that could look at any allegation and
there are obviously lots of allegations
made against police officers
in the course of their duty we have
revamped the police investigations
structure over the last couple of years
the independent office of police conduct
now looks at
all sorts of complaints that are lodged
with them
by the public but critically also
the met police in particular
have ramped up their internal um
professional standards organization if
you like and in particular they're
vetting so for example earlier this year
they started routine vetting of officers
uh social media output uh to make sure
that they were picking up whatever
intelligence they can look there's going
to be lots of lessons that we need to
learn from this horrible episode and you
know my job as i say is to hold the
police to account make sure they learn
those lessons and they implement the
actions that are needed to make sure we
can avoid this kind of horrible incident
in the future
my son's girlfriend is say approached by
what who claims to be
an undercover officer as she's walking
home
tomorrow what do i tell her to do
well the first thing to say is officers
rarely deploy singly
when officers are sworn as a constable
they do actually swear that if there's
an incident they're off duty i am plain
clothes that they have a duty to
intervene uh to protect life and
safeguard the public
but if anybody has any doubts about a
police officer um then obviously they
are they should re question the officer
about
their what they're doing and why they're
doing it if there are any doubts at all
they should ask to either speak to the
control room using the officer's radio
or if in doubt call 999 and ask a
question um you know the the the what
sort of society have we come to mr
malthus where we are so doubting
somebody who says they're a police
officer that we think that we have to
dial 999 to check
well
okay i completely understand and that is
the the as i say the devastating
consequence of this awful man's actions
is that he's undermined the good work of
of thousands and thousands of police
officers not just the current serving
ones but all those police officers that
have served over the decades previously
and it's worth remembering that of
course that those thousands of police
officers across the country are doing
amazing things every day to keep us safe
but these kind of stories do raise
question marks in people's minds i can
understand particularly given the
circumstances and i think it would be
perfectly reasonable
in similar circumstances for somebody to
question the officer
seek reassurance if that means speaking
get asking them to identify themselves
by speaking to the control room uh or
calling in 999 if they feel in danger
then i'm afraid that's where we've got
to